tout je m'aperçoive deux fois vous avez
été battu à l'élection pêche de france
ces exhibitions gallimard ont refusé
votre livre tristes tropiques pare-brise
marins n'ont pas trait sur ses pattes
récent pic d'audience étaient sceptiques
vais être anthropologie ce truc là ses
trois échecs
est-ce que cet épuisant pour vous est ce
que c'est et ça a été des blessures dans
votre vie les échecs au collège de
france il très profondément
à tel point que ce sont les échecs au
collège de france qui sont la cause de
tristes tropiques
parce que jamais je leur ai osé écrire
triste d'être pete c'est-à-dire un livre
où je dis tout ce qui me passe par la
tête sans le souci est de savoir si
c'est vrai ou si c'est fou mais si je
pensais à l'époque que j'allais faire
une carrière universitaire et j'étais
absolument convaincu que c'était terminé
oui d'ailleurs tristes tropiques vous le
dis dans le livre a pas été très bien
accueilli par les ethnologues vos
confrères été accueilli par les
critiques littéraires très bien même
failli enfin vous voyez pire le prix
goncourt s'il avait été un roman en
effet une déclaration de la cage disons
alors autre chose vous dit ceci pour
plusieurs ethnologue et pas seulement
pour moi la vocation technologique fait
peut-être en effet un refuge contre une
civilisation un siècle
mais quand vous décidez de venir et
naulleau vous êtes très jeune j'avais
vingt et quelques années alors déjà vous
étiez en lutte en guerre contre la
civilisation contre le siècle était déjà
mal dans ce siècle
j'étais à la fois même tout enfant et
prix du passé et prix de la nature est
d'une nature aussi intacte qu'on pouvait
la trouver et je crois que derrière
cette vocation ethnologique il n'y a pas
eu seulement le malaise dans le siècle
la curiosité pour les hommes mais aussi
le désir de vivre dans une nature qui
était encore telle qu'elle pouvait
exister il ya des millénaires où il
disait ni même des centaines de
millénaires